we cut bangs guys
new hair new Kim yeah Kim Kardashian's
changing up her look lit and fine and
crazy that's the beauty Mogul debuting
her new curtain bangs with her long
brunette hair all while having fun with
the man behind the locks hair stylist
Chris Appleton
what was that Chris
sing it I want to hear you
[Music]
so cute
we cut bangs guys
and notice the song Kimmy's listening to
it's Ariana Grande's 2019 song Imagine
[Music]
we cut bangs guys
well Kim's post caught Ari's attention
the singer shared the video on her story
and commented my sweet do whatever you
want whatever you want whatever feels
natural be yourself and it seems there's
no bad blood between Kim and Ariana
after they both famously dated Pete
Davidson yeah Bible Ari embarked on a
whirlwind romance with Pete in 2018 with
him proposing to her just weeks after
getting together I was as happy
I'm just be crying like out of Happiness
literally lately however four months
later they called off their engagement
fast forward to 2021 Kim and Pete start
dating after she hosted Saturday Night
Live I like you just the way you are now
Are You Gonna Kiss Me Or Not I sure am
Jasmine
he's just super genuine and it's just
really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing
but after nine months together the two
called it quits you just gotta roll with
it and when it comes to Kim and Ari's
friendship it seems the singer has been
close with the Kardashian fan for a
while you'll remember Kim's momager Kris
Jenner was iconically in Ariana's thank
you next video I am so excited it's
gonna be so funny this is the first time
that I've ever been in a professional
music video with an iconic artist
and someone I admire very much
[Music]
yeah so it's no surprise there's nothing
but love between Kim and Ariana today
[Music]